hi my name is Aneesa Ramirez welcome to
my lab at Yale University today I'd like
to talk to you about the weird materials
that we use in space in robots and in
your mouth I'm talking about shape
memory alloys these are metals with a
memory in order to understand how these
materials work we've got to talk about
organizing atoms organize sometimes
they're in rows sometimes they're
diagonally from each other here's a set
of books to demonstrate my point where
the dots represent atoms right now
they're organized one way however with a
small shift I can push the top of these
books and now the atoms are organized a
different way atoms organized just like
we organize ourselves sometimes they're
in rows sort of like airplane seats and
that's one phase and sometimes they're
slightly diagonal from each other sort
of like stadium seats are in the movie
theater and that's another phase and
then they can move from one phase to
another quite seamlessly and we call
this a phase change you may be familiar
with phases when you think about water
there's the liquid solid and gas phase
well in this case we're talking about
two phases but they're both solid and
the motivation to move from one phase to
the other is as fundamental as fire
phase changes occur with heat let's look
at a phase change in action here I have
a piece of shape memory wire it's made
out of nickel titanium and here's my
lighter what I'm gonna do is wrap this
around my finger I'm gonna heat it with
my lighter and I want you to observe
what happens when I do so watch this
here it is wrapped around wow that's
amazing
that's so amazing let's do it again
not only is it amazing it's kind of
weird because metals don't do that here
I have a paperclip if I were to heat
that up I'd get nothing what we just
observed in the wire was a phase change
that we can see when the wire was cold
it was actually in this configuration
sort of like stadium seats diagonal from
each other this is called monoclinic
when the atoms are in the wire and the
wire is hot they're arranged in this
configuration sort of like airplane
seating we call this cubic and the atoms
can shift from one to the other with
heating and cooling and they can do this
forever
now where are these materials used well
tonight when you look into the sky shape
memory alloys or at work they're on Mars
they're used in the Mars rover and
they're used to move the cover for the
solar panels back on earth they're used
to open up clogged arteries as stents
they're also used to move robots also
they're used to move teeth in braces see
when it comes to shape memory alloys I'm
pretty committed so as you can see the
small shift that atoms make can give
rise to huge changes and by
understanding the way that they behave
we can make materials that make the
world a better place I'm Aneesa Ramirez
thank you for joining me in my lab at
Yale University and I hope that you'll
join us for another material marvel